now at this present time you can then I
mean it doesn't matter which one of
these you want to do in order it's not
like one depends on the other and you
can solve them completely independently
at this point okay
who feels like I'm not gonna make you
come up and do it but who feels like
they would be confident right now from
this launching pad to say yep I know how
to find the greatest coefficient or the
greatest to him heads up straight so
about half of you okay he's not gonna do
that half of you off you go the rest of
you let me start to walk you through we
will begin with the coefficient just
because it's simpler
okay there's less stuff flying around in
there okay if I want the greatest
coefficient okay I want to compare this
guy with the next guy T of K plus 1
so mayor there's a different color in
this room so T of K plus 1 is the
coefficient one after this one it's the
the next one along in the line so what
happens is instead of having 10 CK I'm
gonna have 10 C okay it's the next one a
lot okay and then what happens to these
guys these parts of the coefficient well
one of them is going to go up namely
this one and the other one's gonna go
down namely this one okay so my twos and
my threes this one that was K is going
to become K plus 1 it increases and then
this one here 10 minus K it would
decrease that's why it's 9 - okay there
you go
okay now at this point here while your
brain is doing this okay even if you
realize I'm going down the coefficient
node you might as well at the same time
write down the next term the whole term
including the X's as well okay because
um your brain is already sort of wired
this together so you might as well kind
of take advantage of the fact that your
brain has done that work already okay so
the coefficient at the front all stays
the same
I don't know Sarah
and now come the X's here they are so
there's X x ^ xx - 3 there's gonna be k
plus 1 okay now that still is the X
that's still the same number of X's
right sorry still the same number of K's
rather cuz it's K replaced by K plus 1
but when you have a plus one there it's
also going to be multiplied by that
negative three does that make sense
so you're not just saying plus one
you're actually saying plus one like so
okay so therefore there's going to be 20
minus 3k minus three you see how those
are interacting so in fact it's a fixed
set of X I don't need that in this
particular spot this will not be xx
minus 3k anymore
it'll be 17 minus 3k all right so when
we get to working out the greatest term
we're going to use that that guy over
there instead of this guy we'll compare
those two right now to remind you what
we want is to say to find the greatest
coefficient the coefficients will grow
and grow and grow and grow until some
magic spot the spot that I'm interested
in and then they will decrease okay
so I want to know when is that growing
time okay when is it that the next
coefficient continues being bigger than
the previous coefficient okay this is
what we're trying to do so to solve this
it's sort of nice if we deal with these
two objects together right so this is
where for those of you didn't put your
hands up right if you're not if your
brain isn't going like straight away to
this this object here I want you to
remember that the reason why we
interacted this guy is because this is
the inequality we are trying to solve
but it looks gross there's so much
common stuff on the left and right hand
sides look at these guys they're so
common if we divide through we will get
something much simpler okay
so to review I'm gonna launch you off
now okay here's the cape coefficient
it's on the denominator here's the k
plus 1 coefficient it's on the numerator
write them down as they are and then
start to tease out which bits are going
to cancel together I mean you're going
to need to write these binomial
coefficients you don't have to write
them back in factorial form because
there's no other way to work out what
cancels with what so how'd it go with
that I'll give you a couple minutes to
get a head start and then I'll show you
my working once that is done in dusted
you arrive here okay now be careful here
you have to watch out for negative sides
and then you want to interpret what the
Dickens is going on okay so and this is
a lot of the problem for some of you
so what I'm going to do first is I'm
going to multiply both sides by this by
the way in about three or two or three
lines I'm not to change the direction of
my inequality but this time I didn't why
don't I have to change the direction of
my inequality at this point because two
K plus two is going to be bigger than
zero and that's actually I mean you're
not gonna lose any marks for not saying
this but I encourage you to say it
because it shows that you're being kept
it helps you be careful with your
inequalities okay so this is positive
don't need to change the direction now I
need to collect some like terms so I'm
gonna I'm gonna subtract two K from both
sides I'm going to subtract 30 from both
sides
oops I am there right I now want to
solve for K so I divide through by
negative five which means my inequality
switches around so I end up with this I
get 28 over five here but it might be
more useful to write that as five and
three fifths is that okay that's right
now what does this mean okay well the
first line that we wrote down when we
started off on this big long messy
inequality the first line that we wrote
down was this T of K plus 1 is greater
than T okay that's what we first wrote
down okay so your solution to this
whatever that means is when that first
line is true we sell it again right what
your solution means is this is when my
original inequality is satisfied so what
are the values that work here because K
can only take on integer values the
values that are less than 5 will be 0 1
2 all the way up until 5 right so
whenever K has one of these values that
means that T of K plus 1 will be bigger
than T of K a clearly are interested in
the biggest one of these right so 0 1 2
is just going to keep on going go
straight to the last one which is 5 okay
if you put K equals 5 into here what
inequality results T of 6 that's the 5
plus 1 is bigger than T of 5
now this clearly tells you which one is
the biggest one it's that guy right and
once you go past this this inequality is
no longer true so term seven doesn't
keep on growing in its merry way it will
be smaller than T six okay but
substituting the biggest value I
possibly can get into your original
inequality is the key a lot of students
like wait is it five or is it six this
is how you know which one it is okay so
now that you've identified that it's
coefficient number six you go back to
your original your general coefficient
and you pop in six okay so I'm gonna get
this coefficient six will be ten C six
two to the power of ten motor six four
and three to the power of six there you
go here's your greatest coefficient